all right candy yes candy where'd you
grow up where are you from originally in
bakersfield bakersfield yes tell me
about your family you had mom and dad
yes
how was you how was your childhood
um they're fighting a lot in my
childhood so they're not together
and my mom she's living off the
government i'm not trying to do that
how long have you been doing this um
since i was 18. and how old are you now
22 22.
so back to your childhood it was how
would you describe it
um
horrible well i didn't like it like
i didn't like being in the house
babysitting kids all day
not being able to be a young child and
go outside and play with other kids
because you were raising your siblings
yes
are you the oldest
no
i got an older brother but i'm like the
oldest girl so
so it was your job to raise
take care of the rest of your siblings
it was
any abuse in your childhood
um i got whoopings you got weapons like
with cords and belts and and sticks
little sticks yeah but nothing worse
than that
not that that's not horrible but uh
did you finish high school
yes
and you guys started doing this at what
age
18 18
how did that happen
um i got pregnant and then i got kicked
out the house
so
yeah
do you need to make money yep
this started in bakersfield
no
my friend it was a friend i had met in
high school and she was telling me like
i could come and make money but
then when i got down here it was a
different story like she had a pen where
so that's how it turned out
so
the pimp is what got you
started
no my friend in high school she lied to
me she said i was just gonna be me and
her making some money and then she had a
dude which was her baby daddy pimp
so yeah
and how did that
work out for you
it didn't work out well
basically she had me
making money for them
while
she was pregnant so i'm basically making
money for her and his baby and she was
telling me like she was trying to help
me but it wasn't it didn't go that way
and currently you're working without a
pimp or with
without
drugs are part of your life or no
no
i try i try some but no
but do you get drunk or
did you drink or
smoke pot just to work
smoke weed
but i don't need it to work but i rather
smoke weed because it calms me down yeah
and tell me about how this work affects
you emotionally
um well
i'm cool with it like i'll be outside
and in the morning time i'll just be
chilling and looking cute
making money
don't nobody really bother me like that
because i stay to myself
tell me about the guys who pick you up
um the guys that pick me up some of them
be cool some of them be
me someone aggressive
some of them like to take their money
back so
that's why i hide my money now
do you carry any kind of weapon or
anything to defend yourself
um i carry my pepper spray sometimes i
have a knife but right now i just carry
my pepper spray
you've had to use it um not yet
what do you think you've learned about
men from doing this
um
that they're like animals
and they lie a lot
they know what they're doing but they
try to act like
to us females that we're like stupid
don't know what they're doing
you been in love before
no no
with that attitude you might not ever
fall in love
i don't want no boyfriend i don't want
no husband
i don't want to be married i just want
to love myself and that's it make some
money
so are you taking care of your daughter
nope she's at home with my mom
they living off the government
and i'm trying to make a way
we me and my baby's not about to do that
you're trying to support you and your
daughter
[Music]
what makes you happy now
um just making money and saving up
you're saving money yes that sounds like
it's a dangerous lifestyle isn't it
i hear that from a lot of the girls yes
but it depends on your mindset and how
you're moving what do you do to protect
yourself
um
to protect myself i mean like so have
you had all the terrible things i've
heard from other girls happen to you um
i had a dude make me suck his his d
without a condom before but that's about
it
i feel like i don't really get bad karma
because i'm a good girl so i don't know
what was the best example of a loving
relationship you saw as a young girl
between a man and a woman
not this nothing
are you lonely
um yes
it's gonna be hard to meet a guy i would
think when you're doing this kind of
work
um
well i have my own group of men
to
choose from
if if i'm like lonely lonely
this is this doing this work
build up your self-esteem or knock it
down or
um to me it made me more confident
like i don't care nobody thinks of me
because i know myself and i know i can
do
what's the hardest part of this
lifestyle for you
um
picking your dates because you don't
know if they're trying to be weird
trying to kill you or something
just guys you'll turn down
i was trying to go off my intuition
so what kind of things will you see in a
guy that'll make you say
no thanks um if he's smoking or drinking
if he'd been too aggressive like if he
being scary like him on date me because
i look young i just tell him to go like
and be scared just
go have any regrets in your life
um
yeah
about my money i should have been saving
it up or doing something else with it
instead of it just letting me go freely
do you have friends
no i stay to myself
less problems
what advice would you give to a young
girl who's thinking of doing this kind
of work
um i would tell them
stay home
until you like 20
because it's a lot i had to learn and
i'm still learning i still don't know
everything
it's a crazy job it's such unusual
skill set you need
you have to adapt to every different guy
that'll that you'll meet throughout the
night
yeah
but
mines i like to keep them coming back so
i don't have to
deal with all other stuff yeah regulars
are nice right yes
you get asked to do things like have sex
without a condom you mentioned that
earlier
i don't know i don't do that
i don't play none of that you get asked
yeah
but i don't do that
how much money were you making tonight
a night
if i'm really standing out there i'll
probably make over a band because seven
hours
already a band i got
that's good money
you think you're addicted to this fast
money um yes
it's gonna be hard to go back to a
regular job after this
i am trying to be a regular person
though
i'm trying to be
rich i'm trying to be up there is that
your is that your goal
do you have other things you like to do
in your life
um
no i just want to save some money
and
get a house i already got a car
i'm just trying to put my cell phone in
the position where i'm good for life do
you see yourself doing this for
until you're 30 35 something like that
no probably till like 25 26
because when i'm 26 if i'm still not
where i'm where i want to be then it's
not working i should be where i want to
be by that time
candy what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life um
in your 22 years
don't be too nice don't be too sweet or
people will run over you
all right candy thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you be careful out there okay
thanks
you